maxime thiébaut docteur en droit public
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france cet article 24 jeux très
controversé a donc été réécrit en
urgence par le gouvernement ont été
rajoutés les formes suivantes sans
préjudice du droit d'informer le
caractère manifeste de porter atteinte
également aux forces de l'ordre en
diffusant leur image est ce que cela
comme le flou juridique
ou alors est ce que finalement sur le
terrain le doute ne bénéficiera pas de
toute façon aux forces de l'ordre et à
leur interprétation de la situation lors
de manifestations on reste dans matilla
ge la réalité elle est très simple c'est
en réalité on peut déjà défendre les
policiers les gendarmes qui viendraient
avoir des messages de haine diffusés sur
les réseaux sociaux
la loi le permet le problème c'est
qu'elle n'est pas appliquée on a en
france un dre laxisme judiciaire qui
fait que nos magistrats sont laxistes
avec les auteurs d'appel à la haine sur
les réseaux sociaux
cette proposition de loi est cet article
24 qui a été adopté hier par l'assemblée
nationale
je compte sur le sénat et le conseil
constitionnel pour pour venir rejeté cet
article est liberticide et cet article
il vient tout simplement créer un outil
dissuasif c'est à dire qu'un manifestant
qui nuit au cours d'une manifestation
verrait avoir une intervention des
forces de l'ordre pourrait être amenée à
tout simplement un film et cette action
et lors du moment où il va filmer les
policiers les gendarmes en train
d'intervenir pourrait considérer que ce
film a été fait dans le but de porter
atteinte à l'image des gendarmes et des
policiers qui interviennent et donc ces
policiers pourraient interpeller toute
personne qui serait en train de filmer
une opération de police afin de pouvoir
mettre fin à ce qu'on appelle un délit
flagrant alors la réalité c'est que à
partir du moment où ces gens là serait
arrêté sera interpellé et emmené dans la
staff et des gendarmes les policiers on
verrait finalement ils ont simplement
diffuser les images
sans vouloir nuire aux policiers aux
gendarmes mais en attendant eba ces gens
là n'auraient plus loin de manifester et
deuxièmement l'objectif même de la
diffusion des images c'est à dire
l'information aurait été stoppée parce
que ces personnes là ont été
interpellées et donc c'est pour ça que
je suis vraiment où je suis vraiment
contre 7
cette proposition de loi parce que à mon
sens est là
seul objectif d'empêcher de filmer les
opérations de police lors du match 1 de
l'ordre
il ya un propos aussi de gérald darmanin
qui a beaucoup choqué le ministre de
l'intérieur a appelé les journalistes à
se déclarer auprès de la préfecture
lorsqu'ils couvrent des manifestations
alors il est revenu sur ses propos en
lait précisant en expliquant que ce
n'était pas obligatoire de se déclarer
en préfecture mais ce que le mal n'est
pas déjà fait ce qu'avec de telles idées
on arctique pas dans les esprits
finalement le fait qu'il faut une
autorisation pour couvrir les
manifestations si on veut que tout se
passe bien mais le mal est fait parce
que l'esprit est dit c'est à dire qu'on
voit l'esprit de ce gouvernement tu
feras cynique et de ce ministre de
l'intérieur qui n'aiment pas la liberté
de la presse comme j'ai dit cette
proposition de loi là pour seul objectif
de dissuader les gens de leur vélo recul
de lever leur téléphone pour filmer une
opération de police quand on voit le
ministre de l'intérieur dit en interview
dire en conférence de presse sans avoir
préparé que en réalité les journalistes
doivent attendre l'autorisation pour
pouvoir être protégé dans l'exercice de
leur métier
le problème est là et la réalité nous
saute aux yeux c'est à dire que le mini
intérieur a beau ramer dans tous les
sens aujourd'hui pour venir dire le
contraire c'est à dire que les
journalistes sont libres
le fond est que les journalistes d'après
lui devrait se manifester auprès de la
préfecture de police de paris où tout
préfectures françaises avant d'aller à
une manifestation afin de protéger
pourquoi parce que son objectif sa
vision du maintien de l'ordre c'est
d'empêcher toute revendication est
d'interpeller toute personne qui
viendrait à filmer une opération de
police pourquoi parce qu'on sait très
bien que ce gouvernement depuis la crise
des gilets jaunes a enfreint à maintes
fois toutes les obligations légales qui
lui impose de respecter la
proportionnalité dans l' usage de la
force
on a vu des forces de police qui
n'étaient pas formés au maintien de
l'ordre intervenir lors des
manifestations de gilet jaune et faire
un usage disproportionné de la force
avec des usages du nbd qui n'étaient pas
proportionnées lits nécessaires et en
fait que de faire aujourd'hui ministre
de l'intérieur c'est qu'on puisse plus
voir c'est usage disproportionné de la
force et ça c'est une véritable honte
dans un état de droit et donc je
m'oppose avec eux avec beaucoup de force
à toutes ses dispositions à toute cette
philosophie de maintien de l'ordre
psychologie de notre ministre de
l'intérieur qui est contraire à l'état
de droit tout dernier mot assez
rapidement si vous le voulez bien la
mission première de cette proposition de
loi telle qu'elle a été présentée et de
protéger les forces de l'ordre qui sont
parfois violemment bousculé sur les
réseaux sociaux cela c'est en fait est
ce que il est possible aujourd'hui de
trouver un juste équilibre entre noms
diffusion de l'image des forces de
l'ordre pour les protéger et la liberté
d'informer ou alors est-ce qu dès le
départ l'équation est tout bonnement
impossible mais l'équation est tout à
fait possible parce que la loi existe
déjà pour permettre aujourd'hui
d'attaquer devant la justice les auteurs
de diffusion d'image dont le but serait
de porter atteinte aux policiers ou
gendarmes
la loi existe il suffit de l'appliquer
dans ce pays on n'applique pas les lois
sur la d9 magistrat laxiste déjà et
deuxièmement le seul objectif de cette
proposition de loi je le répète c'est
tout simplement de dissuader les gens de
filmer les opérations de police et ça
c'est une honte parce que la police
comme la gendarmerie sont des services
publics et elles sont en tant que
service public
soumise à une obligation de transparence
et le service public la force publique
telle qu'elle est définie un déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen est
une force au service du public qui doit
rendre des comptes
et pour rendre des comptes on doit faire
preuve de transparence et donc être
filmés merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le
temps de répondre à nos question
d'accepter bon docteur en droit public 1